the department of education has released  new proposed fixes to the student loan  industry coming as the current federal  student loan payment pause is set to  expire that expiration date is august  31st not only are government officials  working on revamping the national  forgiveness program but also expand it  still some say it doesn't go far enough  what is your message to people who want  the administration to cancel student  debt i will tell those folks too that we  haven't been  sitting idle since day one there's over  26 billion dollars in loan forgiveness  that has happened already  the department of education hasn't  decided whether to extend the pause on  repayment but some conservatives do want  it to expire still nearly 200  organizations are urging the president  to keep his campaign promise